Film trailers were originally created to display
an upcoming movie’s general synopsis, encouraging
people to give the movie a chance.
Now film trailers have become their own art
form.
With a killer editing job and an unforgettable
soundtrack, a movie’s trailer can evoke
a variety of emotions in a two minute spot.
However, not all movies can live up to their
incredible trailers.
Here are 10 Amazing Trailers that Were Better
than their Movies.
Suicide Squad
After years of Marvel releasing one awesome
superhero movie after another, DC has trailed
behind attempting the same with lackluster
results.
The summer of 2016 seemed to mark a change
for DC.
After the spring release of Batman V Superman
disappointed, it was up to the Suicide Squad
to bring some much needed vigor to Gotham
City.
The first trailer for Suicide Squad is hard
to beat with its Bohemian Rhapsody soundtrack,
big guns, fast cars, and likeable antiheroes.
The trailers that followed were equally eye
popping with copious amounts of Harley Quinn
screen time.
The film was certainly entertaining but failed
to live up to its truly spectacular trailer.
Star Wars Episode 1 The Phantom Menace
The Phantom Menace was one of the most highly
anticipated films of the 1990s.
Star Wars fans were practically salivating
over the first trailer and once it was released
it appeared that it was worth the wait.
The iconic music and the lightsabers were
all accounted for as well as an appearance
by none other than the always insightful Yoda.
Along with the familiar Star War elements,
there were new characters like Darth Maul
and Jar Jar Binks.
But, alas, The Phantom Menace just did not
live up to its hype or the energetic trailer
and the introduction of Jar Jar Binks only
made it worse.
The Blair Witch Project
Watching The Blair Witch Project trailer today
is a completely different experience than
it was when it was released in 1999.
When the film was first promoted as a real
found footage piece, it was a time when found
footage movies were not a dime-a-dozen.
There were viewers who believed that the three
campers, who went searching for The Blair
Witch, actually went missing.
This was thanks to the pitch perfect marketing
of the film.
The trailer is distressing with its troubling
footage and limited reveal of the events in
the film, making it even more mysterious.
The film itself has frightening moments but
the simplicity of the trailer is more ominous
than a feature length film could manage.
The Strangers
The Strangers is definitely one of the most
frightening horror films made in the last
decade but the trailer is hard to beat.
The 2008 film starring Liv Tyler and Scott
Speedman follows a couple whose secluded farm
home is invaded by three mysterious strangers
in creepy masks.
While the film holds up and is scary enough
to avoid staying home alone for a while, the
trailer is so unsettling it makes the actual
film feel like a relief.
There’s the eerie music playing on a record
that begins to skip, the appearance of a masked
figure coming out of the darkness, the extended
silence when suddenly an ax goes crashing
through the front door.
It is a truly nerve wracking trailer which
culminates with a final moment of dialogue
explaining that the only reason the couple
was chosen was because they were home.
Who needs the movie?
The trailer is enough to spark more than enough
nightmares.
Watchmen
Director Zack Snyder certainly has a way with
making films visually stunning which is probably
why the trailers for his films are so much
better than the actual film.
Films like 300, Sucker Punch and Watchmen
are each a feast for the eyes but the execution
of the story tends to fall short.
Watchmen may be the biggest disappointment
considering the beloved graphic novel already
had unreasonably high expectations from fans.
The release of the first Watchmen trailer
alluded to Snyder pulling off the impossible
with a film that could not look any cooler.
The spectacular visuals accompanied by the
Smashing Pumpkins song, "The Beginning is
the End is the Beginning" makes for a phenomenal
trailer.
Unfortunately, the film is just a little too
long and is unable to sustain the same element
of cool.
Spiderman 3
The trailer for Spiderman 3 gives audiences
the impression that not only is the film going
to live up to the two previous films but also
get darker, crazier, and more entertaining.
The presence of Venom provides even more of
a thrill to comic book fans.
Unfortunately, the film is not an epic superhero
film but rather a much too long final entry
to the Tobey Maguire Spider Man franchise.
Peter Parker turning bad is just ridiculous
in large part because Tobey Maguire’s bad
Spidey is not as much sinister as it is laughable.
There are weird dance scenes and awful hairstyles
that find their way into the cluttered mess
of Spider-Man 3.
No one would ever suspect how much of a bummer
the movie actually was based on the engaging
and thrilling trailer.
Pearl Harbor
The trailer for the 2001 film Pearl Harbor
paints a much different picture than the actual
film.
The trailer shows a few sentimental scenes
of children outside, couples in love, and
the general Norman Rockwell style of American
life in 1941 until harrowing scenes of the
Pearl Harbor attack inform the audience that
this film will be filled with a history lesson
and finely executed action scenes.
The trailer also shows actors Kate Beckinsale,
Josh Hartnett and Ben Affleck rounding out
an exciting historical war film.
The actual film is less Historical drama and
more “Dawson’s Creek Goes to War” with
Michael Bay as director.
The film somehow manages to make a real life
devastation take a back seat to the insane
explosions of a big budget film.
Where the Wild Things Are
Where the Wild Things Are was a tricky project
to take on as a feature length film.
The classic children’s book by Maurice Sendak
is a brief tale of a boy who gets a bit rambunctious
with his mother which causes him to be sent
to his room without dinner.
He decides to take a trip to where the wild
things are, becomes the king, and returns
while his dinner his still hot.
That’s pretty much the tale, so it makes
sense that the Spike Jonze film gets a bit
lost trying to extend such a simple story.
The trailer, however, is two minutes of amazement
set to Arcade Fire’s “Crown of Love”.
The pain, imagination and wonder of childhood
is on full display in a trailer that makes
everyone nostalgic for a time when they sailed
over a year, and in and out of weeks and through
a day to where the wild things are.
Joy
David O. Russell’s film loosely based on
Miracle Mop inventor Joy Mangano’s life
could have easily become a dull film about
a housewife who thought of a great idea.
That was not the story Russell wanted to tell.
Apparently Joy had a life that was fascinating
enough to become cinematic.
The actual film is not lacking and while it
may not compare to the previous Russell/Lawrence
pairing Silver Linings Playbook, it is definitely
on par with American Hustle.
However, the trailers for Joy are such knockouts
that it is hard to live up to the expectations.
The music, the stunning visuals and the delivery
of some of best lines in the film come together
in trailers that promise an Academy Award
quality film.
While Lawrence was nominated, the rest of
the film was mostly pushed to the side.
The film may have been a mild disappointment
but only compared to its fantastic trailers.
Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice
There were plenty of expectations for a Batman
versus Superman film which pitted the two
DC giants against each other in a knock out
drag out fight.
The second official trailer may be the best
by providing scenes of Clark Kent and Bruce
Wayne officially meeting while Lex Luther
comments on Clark Kent’s strong handshake.
The trailer also shows us the big bad Doomsday
who is there to cut in with his own fight
against the superheroes.
Wonder Woman shows up at the end to really
bring home what kind of spectacle the film
promises to be.
The film is entertaining enough but it also
goes off the rails quite a few times before
the fine ending.
There was no need to drag out the backstories
when there is action to be had and new problems
in Metropolis and Gotham to be solved and
the trailer seems to understand that better
than the film
What do you think of our list?
Were there any movies that didn’t live up
to their incredible trailers?
Let us know in the comments.
Don’t forget to subscribe to the Screen
Rant channel to see more videos like this
one.